SNC
: THE JUDGE IS GOING TO ASK YOU
TOMORROW HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
PLEAD?
ARE YOU GOING TO SAY ANYTHING
BEYOND NOT GUILTY?
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE A
STATEMENT IN COURT TOMORROW?
>> NO, I DOUBT IT.
I JUST SAY NOT GUILTY.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
>> THAT IS THE PLEA DONALD TRUMP
SAYS HE WILL ENTER TODAY AT HIS
ARRAIGNMENT, ADDING THAT HE WILL
NOT MAKE A STATEMENT DURING THIS
INITIAL COURT APPEARANCE.
HE DOES FACE 37 COUNTS RELATED
TO THE ALLEGED MISHANDLING OF
NATIONAL DEFENSE DOCUMENTS AND
AN ALLEGED SCHEME TO CONCEAL
THEM FROM INVESTIGATORS.
JOINING US NOW IS ATTORNEY DAVID
SCHOEN.
HE WAS ONE OF TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING HIM DURING HIS
SECOND IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
HE ALSO REPRESENTED EX-TRUMP
ADVISER STEVE BANNON IN 2022
AFTER BANNON WAS INDICTED FOR
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
IT'S REALLY GOOD TO HAVE YOU,
GOOD MORNING.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, GOOD
MORNING.
>> WOULD YOU AGREE THAT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST LEGAL ISSUES FOR
BOTH TEAMS IN THIS CASE AS IT
PROCEEDS IS WHETHER OR NOT ONE
OF TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS EVAN
CORCORAN'S NOTES AND AUDIO
RECORDINGS ARE ALLOWED IN AS
EVIDENCE.
YOU KNOW EVAN CORCORAN REALLY
WELL.
D.C. COURTS ALLOWED THAT CRIME
FRAUD EXCEPTION TO BE PIERCED,
BUT FLORIDA COULD BE A DIFFERENT
STORY, RIGHT?
>> I THINK YOU'RE 100% RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S A BIG ISSUE IN THE
CASE BECAUSE IT RELATES BOTH TO
THE RETURN OF THE GRAND JURY
INDICTMENT AND POTENTIALLY TO
THE TRIAL.
THERE'S ACTUALLY RELATIVELY
RECENT CASE, 2021 CASE FROM THE
11th CIRCUIT, WHICH IS THE COURT
OF APPEALS THAT SITS OVER THIS
COURT IN THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF FLORIDA, AND THAT CASE HAD TO
SORT OF TRY TO FLESH OUT THE --
IT'S CALLED THE GRAND JURY
SUBPOENA, THEY HAD TO TRY TO
FLESH OUT THE CRIME FRAUD
EXCEPTION BECAUSE REMEMBER, ONE
OF THE MOST SACROSANCT
PRIVILEGES WE HAVE IN THE LAW IS
THE ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
HOWEVER, THE LAW RECOGNIZES THIS
CRIME FRAUD EXCEPTION.
THERE'S TWO PRONGS TO IT.
ONE IS THAT THE COURT HAS TO BE
CONVINCED THERE WAS A
CONVERSATION RELATED TO THE
FURTHERANCE OF A CRIME OR
POSSIBLE CRIME.
THAT'S A VERY LOW HURDLE, BUT
THEN THE SECOND PRONG IS WAS THE
CONVERSATION AT ISSUE RELATED TO
THE FURTHERANCE OF THE CRIME.
THE 11th CIRCUIT SORT OF PUNTED
IN THAT CASE SAYING THEY DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE TO DECIDE HOW STRICT
THOSE PARAMETERS ARE REGULATED,
BUT THAT TRADITIONALLY THE
COURTS HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY LESS
RESTRICTIVE IN SHOWING THAT THE
CONVERSATION WAS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE CRIME.
THE ISSUE HERE WILL BE JUDGE
HOWELL APPARENTLY HAD CORCORAN'S
NOTES, HIS PRIVATE NOTES TO
HIMSELF, NOTES REGARDING HIS
INTERACTIONS WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TURNED OVER IN WHOLESALE
FASHION TO THE GOVERNMENT.
THERE'S A QUESTION THERE WITH
ANY PRIVILEGE THAT'S PIERCED,
THE LAW IS YOU ONLY PIERCE IT TO
THE EXTENT IT'S REASONABLY
NECESSARY.
IF THE TURNOVER WAS FAR TOO
BROAD OR WAS TOO BROAD, IT COULD
HAVE TAINTED THE GRAND JURY
PROCESS.
IF THE GRAND JURY WAS EXPOSED TO
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE NOTES
THAT REALLY WEREN'T -- SHOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER BASED ON
CRIME FRAUD EXCEPTION, THEN THE
ISSUE CAN COME UP AGAIN AT
TRIAL.
ASSUMING THE JUDGE DOESN'T
DISMISS THE INDICTMENT BASED ON
THIS TAINT OR ALLEGED TAINT,
THEN IT WOULD COME UP AT TRIAL
AGAIN WHETHER THEY'RE
ADMISSIBLE.
AND IF THEY ARE ADMISSIBLE, THE
FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS IT OPENS
THE DOOR FOR EVAN CORCORAN TO
TESTIFY.
I THINK HIS TESTIMONY, QUITE
FRANKLY, WOULD BE FAVORABLE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN EXPLAINING
HIS NOTES AS DAMNING AS THEY
MIGHT SEEM NOW ON THE FACE OF
THEM, I THINK HIS TESTIMONY
WOULD BE FAVORABLE TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> CAN I ASK, YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN LISTENING TO YOUR RESPONSE
TO THIS INDICTMENT AND SOME OF
YOUR INTERVIEWS OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME SOUND FROM
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR AND
GET YOUR REACTION TO IT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF EVEN HALF OF IT IS TRUE,
THEN HE'S TOAST.
I MEAN, IT'S A PRETTY -- IT'S A
VERY DETAILED INDICTMENT, AND
IT'S VERY, VERY DAMNING.
AND THIS IDEA OF PRESENTING
TRUMP AS A VICTIM HERE, A VICTIM
OF A WITCH HUNT IS RIDICULOUS.
>> DAVID, YOU HAVEN'T PRESENTED
HIM AS A VICTIM OF A WITCH HUNT,
BUT YOU HAVE SAID YOU BELIEVE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT HOLES IN
AN INDICTMENT THAT THE FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL SEEMS TO
BELIEVE IS PRETTY ROCK SOLID.
WHAT ARE THEY?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, MY ISSUE
WITH FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR IS I THINK THAT EVERY
LAWYER HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
POINT OUT THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, TO THE EXTENT HE
SAYS, WELL, IF THIS THING IS
TRUE OR EVEN HALFWAY TRUE IS
VERY DAMNING.
IT'S A SERIOUS INDICTMENT, AND
EVERY FEDERAL CASE OR OTHER CASE
HAS TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY, BUT
THERE ARE DEFENSES TO THE CASE,
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
JUDGE ANY CASE BASED ON THE
INDICTMENT.
IT WOULD BE LIKE WATCHING THE
PROSECUTION PUT ON THEIR CASE
WITHOUT ANY CROSS EXAMINATION
AND SAYING, WELL, HE MUST BE
GUILTY.
SO THE ALLEGATIONS ARE SERIOUS,
BUT THEY'RE JUST ALLEGATIONS AT
THIS POINT.
LISTEN, I THINK THERE ARE PLENTY
OF DEFENSES INCLUDING IT'S A
VERY INTERESTING CHOICE TO
CHOOSE THE STATUTE OF THE 31
COUNTS, 18 USC 793 E.
I THINK THEY DID THAT IN ORDER
TO GET AROUND THE IDEA OF
WHETHER THE DOCUMENTS ARE
CLASSIFIED OR DECLASSIFIED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
CLASSIFIED FOR ONE TO BE GUILTY
UNDER THAT STATUTE.
HOW FAR, THERE ARE SEVERAL
PRONGS, ELEMENTS TO THE STATUTE
INCLUDING WHETHER THE PERSON WAS
AUTHORIZED TO HAVE THE
DOCUMENTS, AND THIS IS WHERE
THEIR DEFENSE OF PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT IS GOING TO PLAY
INTO IT AND SO ON.
THERE ARE A LOT OF LEGAL ISSUES
TO BE FLESHED OUT --
>> CAN YOU JUST SAY, I'M VERY
CURIOUS, IT'S NOT CITED IN THE
INDICTMENT, THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH AGENCY DOCUMENTS TAKEN BY
THE PRESIDENT.
HE HAS NO RECORDS OF SAYING
THESE AGENCY DOCUMENTS ARE MY
PERSONAL RECORDS, EVEN IF HE DID
TRY AND DO THAT.
WHERE DOES THE PRA COME IN HERE
AS A DEFENSE?
>> RIGHT, I ACTUALLY HAVE NOT
EMPHASIZED THIS POINT.
I'VE HEARD MANY OTHER PEOPLE
EMPHASIZE IT.
I THINK THE REASON IT GETS LESS
EMPHASIS, PEOPLE WERE GUESSING
BEFORE THE INDICTMENT CAME OUT
IS, AGAIN, BECAUSE THIS
CLASSIFIED ELEMENT ISN'T A PART
OF IT.
PEOPLE GENERALLY WERE TALKING
ABOUT THAT BEFORE BECAUSE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S UNILATERAL RIGHT TO
DECLASSIFY DOCUMENTS WHEN HE'S
IN OFFICE.
HOWEVER, I THINK IT'S RELEVANT
HERE BASED ON THE WILLFULNESS
PRONG, THAT IS DID HE KNOW,
SHOULD HE HAVE KNOWN SOMETHING
HE WAS PROHIBITED BY THE LAW,
GIVEN THE READING OF THE RECORDS
ACT THAT HIS ADVISERS HAVE GIVEN
HIM.
IT GOES TO THE FIRST PRONG
WHETHER HE WAS AUTHORIZED TO
HAVE DOCUMENTS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
ONE THING THAT'S NEVER REALLY
POINTED OUT THESE DAYS IS
TRADITIONAL TLI -- AND YOU MAY
SAY IT'S NOT DIRECTLY RELEVANT,
BUT IT'S SOMEWHAT RELEVANT, THE
TRADITION HAS BEEN FORMER
PRESIDENTS GET REGULAR
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFINGS EVEN WELL
AFTER THEY'RE OUT OF OFFICE AND
ALL THAT.
ONE THING WE HAVE TO REMEMBER IS
THERE IS SOMETHING SPECIAL AND
UNIQUE ABOUT THE POSITION OF THE
PRESIDENCY, WHETHER IT'S A
COMPLETE DEFENSE OR NOT IS A
DIFFERENT QUESTION.
THERE'S SOMETHING TO REMEMBER
ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT'S TRUE, BUT THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE NO RIGHT TO SHOW
OR TALK ABOUT THOSE NATIONAL TOP
SECRETS IN FRONT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO CLASSIFICATION, WHICH IS
WHAT'S ALLEGED HERE IN TERMS OF
THE AUDIO OF THAT MEETING WITH
THE AUTHORS WRITING ON MEADOWS.
LET ME ASK YOU ANOTHER DEFENSE
MADE BY THE PRESIDENT'S ALLIES.
JIM JORDAN MADE THIS REPEATEDLY
ON SUNDAY MORNING, CITING A 1988
SUPREME COURT DECISION WHICH
SAYS THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO CLASSIFY AND
CONTROL ACCESS, THE CONSTITUTION
GIVES HIM THAT POWER.
BUT THAT'S WHILE THEY'RE
PRESIDENT, NOT AFTER, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE CLASSIC
CASE THAT EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT
IN THIS REALM, BUT I'LL TELL YOU
THIS --
>> I JUST WANT TO STICK ON THIS
CASE BECAUSE IT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S ALLIES ARE USING SO
MUCH.
TO ARGUE IT IN THE WAY THAT HIS
ALLIES HAVE BEEN ARGUING IT THAT
IT GIVES HIM THIS RIGHT
POST-PRESIDENCY IS AN INACCURATE
READING OF THAT MAJORITY OPINION
FROM THE SUPREME COURT, RIGHT?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT, THAT IT
GIVES -- EAGEN TALKS ABOUT WHEN
A PERSON IS PRESIDENT.
HOWEVER, I DO WANT TO STRESS
THERE IS A CASE FROM AMY BERMAN
JACKSON, YOU MAY ALSO HAVE HAD
SOMEONE TALK ABOUT ON YOUR SHOW,
JUDICIAL WATCH CASE FROM 2012
THAT HAS A LOT OF LANGUAGE THAT
TALKS ACT THE UNIQUE POWER OF
BILL CLINTON AT THAT TIME WHEN
HE'S PRESIDENT AND AFTER HE'S
PRESIDENT WITH RESPECT TO NOT
JUST PERSONAL RECORDS BUT
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
THERE ARE VERY INTERESTING
ISSUES THAT REALLY HAVE NOT BEEN
FLESHED OUT HERE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO PLAY OUT.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS KIND OF
SITUATION BEFORE.
>> CAN YOU JUST VERY QUICKLY
RELATE IT TO THE JUDICIAL WATCH
CASE IN THE BILL CLINTON CASE,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WERE ABOUT
RECORDINGS THAT HE DID IN WHAT
HE SAID WAS A PERSONAL CAPACITY
WHILE HE WAS PRESIDENT, WHICH I
THINK WOULD FALL UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT OF PERSONAL RECORDS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE THAT BLEEDS
INTO THIS SPECIFIC CASE WHERE,
AGAIN, YOU MADE CLEAR YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN CITING THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
THAT'S ABOUT PERSONAL RECORDS.
THESE ARE ABOUT AGENCY DOCUMENTS
THE PRESIDENT TOOK WITH HIM.
WHAT'S THE LANGUAGE IN THERE YOU
THINK THAT APPLIES HERE?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I HAVE THE PAGE
MARKED WITH THE LANGUAGE
SPECIFICALLY WHEN JUDGE JACKSON
TALKS ABOUT, FIRST OF ALL, THE
LACK OF JUDICIAL REVIEW
GENERALLY FOR ISSUES THAT COME
UP UNDER THE PRA WHEN NARA MAKES
THEIR CLAIMS AND ALL THAT.
HERE'S WHERE I THINK IT'S
RELEVANT, WHETHER IT DIRECTLY
APPLIES OR NOT, I THINK IT'S
RELEVANT TO THE WILLFUL PRONG.
THE QUESTION HERE UNDER 793 E,
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS A THIRD
PRONG, WHETHER THE PERSON BEING
CHARGED WILLFULLY DID IT.
THAT MEANS DID SOMETHING HE KNEW
WAS PROHIBITED BY THE LAW.
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY TO ME, YOU
CAN HEAR FROM THE TAPE IT SEEMS
THAT HE KNEW, YOU KNOW, WHAT HE
WAS DOING HE WASN'T ALLOWED TO
DO IT AND SO ON.
TAPES CAN BE CROSS EXAMINED.
WHAT WERE THE CIRCUMSTANCES, YOU
KNOW, EXACTLY WHAT WAS THE REST
OF THE CONVERSATION, AND SO ON.
AGAIN, WE HAVE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEFENSE ABOUT ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
BUT I THINK IT PLAYS INTO WHAT
WAS IN HIS MIND, WHAT HE
UNDERSTOOD FROM HIS ADVISERS,
RIGHT OR WRONG, ABOUT WHAT HE
HAD THE AUTHORITY TO DO WITH
DOCUMENTS.
>> DAVID SCHOEN, AND YOU MAKE A
GOOD POINT, INNOCENT UNTIL